[Musique]
emad al - chiffre de 1 à 10 4 quoi
combien de 7 dont 3 4 5 6 7
c'est catherine laborde 4,4 et de ma
chérie c'est très simple je le fais avec
toi tu veux l'aider et la limonade
non vous avez vous savez faire vraiment
une bonne discussion est-ce que ça va
est-ce que tu l'as vu at il dit nous
avons fait mon cul d'accord d'accord ok
latrines catherine et mélanie vous allez
vous parler d'abord avec les personnes
âgées
comment allez vous fera ce soir à
nouveau les discussions
oui oui quelqu'un pour tout le monde tu
l'as vu huy a même jugé la russie
bien sûr il était dit adam et encore de
la personne et la vie s'est fait l'écho
de monsieur rené meyer mon papy c'est
une partie c'est une partie non pas
fallu alors attendre
non non ne partez sur son scooter
vous allez retrouver catherine laborde
vous avez l'impression hauteur mais j'ai
peur on se fera elle situe la vue à vous
de venir les sorties
pourtant la perche messieurs bonsoir
monsieur catherine laborde et la baleine
alors je me suis en attente traversant
les gens pourront voir ces maisons 90
quand même vous le regardez cfa la
magnifique la lecture à vous poser
quelques appellations a coûté la vie
j'espère me sépare du lui
malheureusement c'est pas de la chair
elle essayait